Speaker 1: It's great to welcome back to the
program today, Grace Blakely, who is a staff
writer at Tribune magazine and also author
of the book Stolen How to Save the World from
Financialization A Grace.
It's great to have you back on today.
Speaker 3: Great to be here.
Thanks for having me.
Speaker 1: So, OK, let's I want to talk about
whether there will really be any longer term
changes to the economy into the world of work
from the pandemic.
You know, we just kind of generally have this
understanding that things that seem like,
oh, we're never going back, humans forget,
humans re-adapt and things sort of return
to the mean in many cases.
Are there aspects of work and or the relationship
of people to to the economy, particularly
in Western economies, that you think will
be permanently altered as a result of the
pandemic?
Speaker 3: Well, I think as with any crisis,
what happens next is really going to depend
on what we demand and and how we kind of choose
to reorganize society when we when we emerge
from it.
I don't think that we will see a kind of return
to normal, whatever normal was, because, I
mean, even before the pandemic, we had a lot
of quite deep problems with the global economy,
everything from this kind of long term stagnation
in productivity and investment through to
the stagnation in wages, through to the kind
of massive debt crisis that that we were going
through in the US.
People were talking about a corporate debt
bubble.
And even before the pandemic started, which,
of course, fed into a lot of the problems
that we saw at the start.
So there were already all these kind of deep
seeded issues that I raised by my my thoughts.
But imagine that stolen.
So obviously going back to that kind of normal
would not be desirable.
We also then had some kind of more, I suppose,
longer term structural problems to deal with.
So things like, you know, obviously climate
breakdown, global inequality, inequality within
nations as well.
And some of those things have gotten worse
over the course of the pandemic.
So if we look at inequality, for example,
globally, we've seen this big divergence in
outcomes between wealthier states that have
been able to tackle the pandemic, have been
able to have a big stimulus programs, big
programs to support workers and businesses
and states in the global south, which have
suffered from the largest outflow of capital
ever recorded as a result of the pandemic
and are struggling just to be able to kind
of provide the basic services that the populations
need, let alone put in place the measures
that are going to allow them to recover.
And actually a lot of them are kind of on
the verge of defaulting on their debts.
And then, you know, they're not able to access
the vaccine either.
So that divergence is going to be really,
really problematic.
Inequality within countries.
We've seen this big divide between people
who've been able to amass savings and who
will come out of the pandemic, go out and
spend all that money potentially driving a
bit of inflation and everyone else who maybe
has actually seen that debt increase and is
struggling to make ends meet.
So that divide is going to increase as well.
And really what happens next is all going
to be shaped by policy, by, you know, whether
or not we have a kind of just recovery or
whether we see the same sorts of policies
as what we saw after the financial crisis,
where the costs of that crisis were largely
borne by working people
Speaker 1: to pick one micro issue and see
whether you think it's really relevant to
the bigger picture or it's just something
people are liking to write articles about.
There's this idea that, OK, take Manhattan.
There's all this empty office space in Manhattan
because of work from home and small businesses
moving out and big businesses will reduce
their footprint and just reduce the amount
of square footage.
And then you read an analysis which takes
a sort of conservative view on it, which is,
yeah, you know, rents will go down a few percent
in the immediate, but it's still Manhattan.
It's still really expensive.
And then three or four years from now, if
there's not another pandemic, they'll probably
sort of be back to being close to where they
were.
And some of the big offices will be replaced
with coworking spaces.
And it won't really change the big picture
in a serious way, something like that.
Do you think that that even ranks when we
think about, like the systemic changes or
is the analysis that it's a couple percentage
points and it won't really make a difference
is the correct analysis.
Speaker 3: I mean, the big driver of like
real estate prices at the moment is not necessarily
demand.
It's more speculation, particularly in big
cities.
So in places like Manhattan and London, there
has not been the kind of fall in in rents
and particularly in actual house prices that
you would assume would happen as people leave
the capitals when London, for example, the
population has fallen, according to some estimates,
by around seven hundred thousand since the
pandemic started, which is huge.
And that hasn't really been too much of an
impact on rents or or real estate prices.
It's different in different parts of the market,
but broadly speaking, things haven't changed
dramatically.
And of course, the main reason for that is
quantitative easing is this policy adopted
by central banks of creating new money to
purchase assets from private investors, which
is pumping tons and tons and tons of cash
into the financial system.
I think the last time I checked, it was about
nine trillion dollars worth of new money had
been created predominately by the big four
central banks to try and prop up the financial
system and actually to try and keep asset
prices high.
This is what central banks are trying to do
at the moment.
They're trying to keep equities high.
They're trying to keep real estate prices
high, basically, because if those prices were
to fall, that could create a wider financial
crisis, basically because, you know, some
of that is used as collateral for lending.
And if you start to see that fall, you got
kind of debt deflation cycle of the kind that
we saw during the financial crisis.
So policy makers and central bankers are actually
going for high asset prices or at least stable
asset prices, and this model of quantitative
easing is how they're doing it.
And that's likely to be with us for quite
some time now.
A lot of it is going to depend on what happens
in the rest of the economy to do with inflation
and whatever.
But broadly speaking, central bankers know
that the big thing driving asset prices at
the moment is their policies.
And if those policies stop, you could see
quite significant fall in asset prices, which
would have kind of negative implications in
terms of financial stability, but which would
actually probably correct the massive wealth
inequality that we've seen really just go
through the roof, because the pandemic people
like Jeff Bezos becoming extraordinarily wealthy,
basically because money is being plowed into
Amazon shares because of central bank policy.
The same thing is happening in with real estate
as well.
So unless we see like a big shift in policy,
that probably isn't going to change.
Then again, it is hard to see how the pattern
that we've seen over the last 40 years and
just constantly increasing house prices can
continue forever.
So it's a real question as to the interaction
between policy and whether or not we see another
shock that does actually lead to some sort
of correction.
But I wouldn't put any money on house prices
properly falling in the kind of short to medium
term.
Speaker 1: Yes.
Speaking of that, I'd be interested to hear
from you if you have advice for for my audience
about how to interpret.
I mean, just to give an example about the
home prices, because it's something that that's
quite interesting right now.
During twenty twenty, when demand started
to grow in the United States, in suburbs and
smaller cities, for people saying, hey, maybe
I'll just get a bigger place a little bit
further out, work from home, et cetera.
Donald Trump cheered the sign and said, listen,
we're doing OK.
Look at home prices.
They're actually up like this is a sign that
things are good.
In an interview with Newsmax two days ago,
Donald Trump said this inflation stuff is
out of control.
Look at what homes are costing at this point
in time.
No one can get lumber.
And, of course, it's a very transparent political
attack on Joe Biden.
But is there some empirical objective analysis
we can do of to what degree is it good that
the home prices have gone up and to what degree
is it a problem?
Speaker 3: I mean, it depends whether or not
you own a home.
Right.
And this is really the kind of big divide
that we're seeing in politics at the moment,
I think explains a lot of the age divide and
also, to an extent, the kind of regional divide
that we're seeing in politics is that older
homeowners, which is a group that was broadly
created during the nineteen eighties, as you
saw, the liberalization of the financial system.
Right.
People are better able to get mortgages.
They could purchase homes in the UK.
You had mass sell off of formerly publicly
owned housing and it created this class of
homeowners who were able to take advantage
of that massive increase in house prices that
we've seen over the last 50 years become very
wealthy and as a result, become very conservative.
Because if you're on the verge of retirement
or you're already retired, you have a lot
of wealth stored up in your home.
You have a lot of wealth stored up in your
pension.
What do you want?
The main thing that you want is to see house
prices stable and his estate stock prices
going up substantially, going up as well.
If you're a young person, that's the opposite
of what you want, right?
Certainly with house prices like you are probably
struggling to get on the on the on the housing
ladder, maybe struggling to get a mortgage,
maybe you don't have, like, a full time job.
The is the kind of job that will allow you
to get a mortgage, maybe you like self-employed
or precariously employed.
So you're really struggling often to get on
the housing ladder, especially if you're looking
at one of these big cities.
And that is often you're also paying extremely
high rents in the private rented sector.
Right.
And, you know, parts of London, people are
paying up to like 50 percent of their salaries
in rent, which is just extraordinary.
And so obviously, that means you have an interest
in things being different.
Right.
So this divide between people who want things
to broadly stay the same on house prices,
to stay the same, and who are as a result,
becoming quite conservative out of this desire
to hold on to the kind of gains that they've
made versus everyone else who's being shut
out of that system is, I think, probably the
most important divide in politics at the moment.
Speaker 1: So so in a sense, it's sort of
a political football in the sense that you
can argue that housing prices being up is
good or bad, depending on for which group
group you are talking and also what sort of
underlying implications you think it points
to about the economy at large.
Speaker 3: Yeah, exactly.
I mean, you know, economists will will say,
oh, well, house prices going up is good because
you're going to have the wealth effect of
people feeling wealthier because their house
is worth more.
So be, you know, taking equity out of that
house and going on spending it in the economy,
which is good for the economy.
I mean, fine.
Obviously, if you would see a massive fall
in house prices without any corrective measures
put in place, that could have negative implications
for like overall growth.
But actually, there's a structural problem
here, which is that, you know, the fact that
economic growth relies on the.
Increasing wealth inequality, right, and constantly
returns increasing at the very top of the
wealth spectrum is not sustainable.
Speaker 1: Last thing I want to talk about
is in the United States, Republicans for decades
now have been saying this government spending
program is going to make inflation off the
charts.
Obama's stimulus is going to push inflation
off the charts.
Trump's first covid stimulus, second covid.
And they were more or less wrong all along
and inflation has been quite, quite stable.
We now have a situation finally where we're
starting to see some higher inflation numbers.
Some of it is because we're comparing to the
second quarter of twenty twenty when there
was a total demand collapse.
So part of that may be an artifact of that.
It's still sort of remains to be seen.
How should we interpret that?
Like is the idea of the inflationary spiral
when governments do stuff, something we can
just put to bed at this point, or is there
anything to it?
Speaker 3: People get very hysterical about
inflation, and this was kind of a proper neoliberal
talking point during the 1980s.
Yes, basically at that time inflation was
people were actually worried about inflation.
I mean, they would frame it as being worried
about inflation because they could say, well,
it's the price of the goods and services that
you're buying that's going up.
Really, it was a mechanism to discipline organized
labor.
So you saw well, for example, in the US with
the Volcker shock interest rates going through
the roof, it creates a kind of worldwide economic
crisis.
So a debt crisis in the global south.
But it was also used as a tool to create mass
unemployment so that the labor unions could
be broken and this kind of neoliberal model
could be set up.
And since then, we haven't had the same kinds
of back then yet.
They were kind of some issues with inflation.
I mean, a lot of it was actually driven by
the oil price spike rather than anything else.
But inflation hasn't really been too much
of an issue.
And actually, since the financial crisis,
it's been too low.
I mean, you can think about inflationary pressure
as something that happens when the output
gap closes.
So that's the gap between the amount of stuff
that we could be producing if every resource
was being put to use and the amount of stuff
we're actually producing.
Right.
So when you get inflation, it's because you're
starting to get to the point where all the
resources that exist in the economy are being
used to their greatest extent.
Right.
Or maybe more than those resources are being
used or getting some pressure on prices.
But when that isn't happening, so, you know,
there's underemployment, underutilization
of resources, you don't have inflationary
pressure.
And that's what we were seeing because there
was this big shortage in demand that came
from low levels of investment, low levels
of government spending and just general kind
of a lack of optimism about what was going
on in the economy legitimately.
So today what we're seeing is because it's
less about the fact that demand is going up,
demand is going up and it will continue to
go up.
It's more about the fact that the actual amount
that we could produce has contracted so much
so that that kind of longer term supply side
of the economy has really become much more
constrained.
A big reason for that is what's going on in
the rest of the world.
And this is why it's really, really important
for economies in the global north, aside from
the kind of obvious moral reasons to pay attention
to the global economy.
Because if you start to see, you know, say,
the Indian variant spreading throughout the
global south, production shuts down, can't
get access to the commodities that you know,
as massive importers, countries like the US
and the UK need just to kind of get by, then
you will start seeing a huge amount of inflation,
especially since you have all these savings
that middle class people have and they want
to go out and spend in the economy.
So that's, I think, the biggest potential
pressure that we're going to be seeing inflation
wise from now on.
And ultimately, it's going to hurt working
class people more than it's going to hurt
middle class people.
Speaker 1: No question.
No question about that.
We've been speaking with Grace Blakely, staff
writer at Tribune magazine and also author
of Stolen How to Save the World from Financialization.
Grace, always great speaking with you.
Speaker 3: And you, too.
Thanks.
David.